[Music]
visual intelligence is the concept that
we see more than we can process and it's
the idea of thinking about what we see
taking in the information and what do we
really need to live our lives more
purposefully and do our jobs more
effectively what I ask the people in the
art of perception to do one of them is
looking down at a piece of paper and the
other one is looking at the painting and
then they have one minute to describe
what it is that they see to their
partner and the partner has to sketch
what they hear and it's not about the
artwork it's not about how well you draw
it's how well can you describe a new set
of unfamiliar data how well do you
listen and how well do you take that
articulation and transfer it to your own
language
[Music]
how many of you said there was a train
coming out of a fireplace and everyone
raises his or her hands and how many of
you reference smoke or steam in your
discussion lots of hands go up and then
I ask the question who mentioned who
articulated that there are no tracks
under the Train and a few astute people
actually raised their hand and said no I
said there were no tracks under the
Train and then I asked who noticed and
then articulated that there was no fire
in the fireplace and hands go up not too
many and then we talk about other
aspects of the painting how many people
mentioned the wood grain on the floor
most people notice the wood grain on the
floor how many people mentioned
wainscoting that kind of paneling on the
walls and I always have some decorative
arts aficionados oh yes I know about
wainscoting and then I say how many of
you mentioned a mantel on the fireplace
lots of hands go up who mentioned
candlesticks lots of hands go up and
then I asked how many of you said there
were no candles in the candlesticks and
people say oh nope never got there and
then I asked okay what really observant
nerd said it's 12:42 or eight oh five on
the clock who got to mention the time
and the reason I asked I have that line
of questioning is because this painting
illustrates a very very important
concept that I transferred from
emergency medicine to a much broader
application and the idea is called the
pertinent negative it's saying what
isn't there in addition to what is there
to actually give a more accurate picture
of what you're looking at so when you
say I see a train coming out of a
fireplace and by the way there are no
tracks under the train and there is no
fire in the fireplace why would you
attempt to say what's not there because
in my third-grade mind if you told me to
draw a fireplace I would draw two sticks
and a fire and smoke in the fireplace
unless you told me not to and if you
told me to draw a pair of candlesticks
I'll draw candles with flames unless you
tell me not to so the pertinent negative
is
this wonderful concept that gives us a
broader way of looking at something
instead of looking at something like
this you look at it like this and here's
the example an example of how you apply
that in the real world the pertinent
negative in a medical situation is when
someone comes into the emergency room
and they have all the symptoms it
appears to the physician they have all
the symptoms of pneumonia pneumonia has
three symptoms symptom one is present
symptom two is present but if symptom
three is absent it's the pertinent
negative you have to say symptom three
is not there therefore it's not
pneumonia so in the real world outside
of medicine how can we use this if we
have an expectation of someone someone's
behavior you expect them to behave a
certain way and then they don't you need
to say it didn't happen
you're evaluating someone on the job
well you did a B and C very well but you
didn't do D E and F so it's looking at
the affirmative and looking at the
negative and the pertinent negative is a
wonderful tool missing missing persons
cases you go to their homes what's not
there the cell phone is not there the
keys are not there the wallet is not
there you're going to have a very
different search for that person if
those things were present instead of
absent so this Magritte painting gives
us this great opportunity to talk about
not just what we see but what we don't
see to give the person who can't see
what we see a much more accurate
description of what they're looking at
[Music]